حول هذه المنطقه واثر على منطقه واسعه جدا
ودمار واسع جدا في هذه المنطقه لذلك هذا
ليس اكبر زلزال في تاريخ الجمهوريه
التركيه بل هي من اكبر الكوارث العالميه
التي حصلت في هذه المنطقه برمتها كل
مؤسسات الدوله وكل مركباتها ووسائلها
ومستلزمتها ومعدتها تتواجد في الميدان
الان وبدات بالعمل
لمدى جهود الانقاذ لها قوه هادمه كبيره
جدا وبالتالي اثرت على عدد كبير جدا من
المواطنين ايضا هناك
تحركات من كل انحاء البلاد الى هذه
المنطقه طبعا هناك
ظروف طقس صعبه جدا وهناك صعوبات ميدانيه
بسبب
الدمار الذي حصل في هذه المنطقه ولكن
العمليات مستمره الى حد الان هناك خطوره
تسببت بها المباني
التي تاثرت من هذه
الزلازل ولكن رغم كل الشروط الصعبه
والظروف الصعبه نستخدم كل امكانيات الدوله
ونقوم بمساعده
واعمال البحث والانقاذ
المواطنين العليقين تحت الانقاذ
اعملي لنا في فرق الانقاذ تعمل الان وهناك
ايضا فرق اضافيه
تزداد بالعمل طبعا هذه الفرق تزداد بالرقم
وتذكى هو عامله ايضا للانقاذ
وهناك عدد كبير ايضا من
المتضامنين في هذه العمليات طبعا هناك
مساعدات ايضا يتم تقديمها في هذا الصدد من
الطعام وشراب وايضا المساعده الاوليه
والمساعدات الطبيه والبطانيات وايضا
المساعدات الاخرى الى حد الان
تم انشاء 44 الف مخيم وارسالها الى هذه
المناطق وايضا
عدد كبير من المعدات الطبيه التي تم
ارسالها ايضا الى هناك طبعا هناك دعم
مستمر للاداريه للادارات المحليه وايضا تم
من المدن الاخرى تم ارسالهم الى هذه
المناطق هناك اعمال مستمره بشكل كثيف
لتقديم الدعم الى هذه المنطقه لاداره
الكارثه هناك ولتنسيق العمليات هناك طبعا
كل وزير في كل منطقه يتواجد لتنسيق لتنسيق
الجماعي لعمليات الانقاذ السيد فؤاد
يتواجد في مركز افاد وينسق عمليه الانقاذ
من هناك ونحن لدينا وزراء معنيين في كل
مدينه ونحن نتواصل معهم باستمرار من اجل
تقديم مساعده اللازمه وايضا من اجل متابعه
كل المستجدات لحظه بلحظه هناك مساعدات
طارئه نقوم بتقديمها واتملكه دعم نقوم
بتقديمه وبالتالي اولا
قمنا بتعيين 100 مليار ليره
كمبلغ اولي لتقديم المساعدات اللازمه
كخطوه اولى هناك خطوط
الهواتف الان
الهواتف النقاله الخطوط الهواتف النقاله
تعمل بشكل سليم وايضا تم ارسال
بعض المعدات وبعض المحطات الاضافيه
والمتحركه الى مناطق ولكن الى حد الان
لدينا بعض الصعوبات في الوصول الى مناطق
الامداد والى مناطق
الانهيارات لذلك نحن نطالب بعدم استخدام
الطرق المؤديه الى هذه المناطق قدر
المستطاع وعدم القيام باتصالات هاتفيه من
اجل التقليل من الضغط على الخطوط الهاتفيه
هناك
بعض الطائرات للخطوط الج قمنا بتخصيصها
لنقل المساعدات هناك اكثر من 1000 سياره
اسعاف تم ارسالها الى هذه المنطقه وهناك
ايضا مروحيه اسعاف تم ارسالها وايضا 5000
موظف وعامل في مجال الصحه تم ارسالهم الى
هذه المنطقه
ولدينا ايضا مشروع اخر العمل على
التبرع بالدم لابقاء مخزون الدم عالي قدر
المستطاع لتقديم المساعدات الطبيه ايضا في
هذا الصدد هناك
فرق البحث والانقاذ يعملون بالاضافه الى
القوات المسلحه التركيه والقوات الامن
وقوات الدرك وايضا القوات الداعمه وقوات
الدفاع المدنيه ايضا يتواجدون هناك تم
زياده ايضا عدد الفرق التي كانت متواجده
في انحاء بلا تم ارسال عدد كبير منها الى
هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى تخصيص
الطائره الطائرات التي تحمل المواد تم
تخصيصها
لنقل المساعدات الى هذه المنطقه طبعا
القوه قوات الامن تتواجد بكل عناصرها الان
في المنطقه وقوات الدرك تتواجد هناك ايضا
مع القوات الخاصه كما انها خصصت عدد كبير
من طائراتها لنقل الشحن الى هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه الى وجود قوات خفر السواحل ايضا
في هذه المنطقه للمساهمه في هذه العمليات
ونعمل الان على التشخيص الدقيق لمدى
انتشار هذا الزلزال في المنطق وبالتالي
خصصنا المسيرات الان للتصوير من الاعلى من
خلالها نقوم على تشخيص المناطق التي
يتواجد فيها
[موسيقى]
المباني المنهاره وايضا
المصابين بهذه الان
تعمل كل
البلديات وتقوم كل البلديات بارسال من
انحاء البلاد تقوم البلديات بارسال
معداتها ومركباتها وكل وسيله يمكننا
استخدامها في هذا
التدخلها لهذه
لعمليات البحث تقوم ببريات بارسالها دون
تمييز السياسي او تمييز توجهي في السياسه
لذلك نحن نشكر ايضا الجميع على هذه
الخطوات وعلى هذه المبادرات
نحن الان نستطيع ان نقول اننا نستطيع
اتخاذ او اننا
قمنا على استمرار هذه العمليات العمليات
البحث
مع الاسف تظهر مشاهد مؤلمه بسبب استمرار
البحث وهناك بعض
الزياده في عدد الوفيات في
الانقاذ حيث
اننا في نرى
اننا نقوم بارسال ايضا المرض المصابين
والمرضى والجرحى الى مرسين والى اسطنبول
والى المدن الاخرى في هذه المنطقه نتقدم
بتعازينا
لشعب التركي ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل
للمصابين وللاشرحى منذ يوم امس كما تعلمون
اننا
اعلنا الحداد وسيتم تنكيس الاعلام حتى
ثاني عشر من شهر
ابريل طبعا الى جانب ذلك نرى ان هناك
الكثير من المسؤوليات التي يتم اتخاذها
الان ونحن نشارك كل المعلومات
والمستجدات بسبب الزلزال وايضا تم تعطيل
المدارس الى شهر فبراير
وايضا تم تعطيل المدارس الى عشرين الى
تاريخ 20 فبراير
في مناطق الزلزال وفي مناطق هذه
الاكارثه وتم تخصيص عدد كبير من المدارس
والمراكز الرياضيه والمراكز الثقافيه
الصحيه والسليمه
للنجينه من هذه
الزلازل
وطبعا يتم التخطيط باستمرار للمئوي
المؤقته يتم العمل على تخصيص بعض الاسئله
الاضافيه الرياضيه ايضا
لهذه
لتدخلها لمساعده الناجين منه هذا
الزلزال وطبعا هناك كما ذكرنا منطقه
انتشار واسعه جدا وبالتالي هناك بعض
المشاكل في الوصول الى حد الان الى بعض
العالقين تحت الانقاض عدد
الوفيات قد وصل الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
وتسعه واربعين
مواطن ولدينا
22,168
جريح ومصاب جراء هذا الزلزال ولكن الى
جانب كل هذه
الاخبار التي نقوم بنشرها او الى كل
مساعينا
لنشر الاخبار السابقه ولاخبار الجميع
بالمستجدات الحديثه ولكن هناك لحد الان
نرى اخبار كاذبه
ونحن الان ليس بوسعنا ان نرحق هذا هو ذاك
لاننا سخرنا كل امكانياتنا لتقديم
المساعدات ولعمليات الانقاذ والبحث عن
المواطنين العالقين تحت الانقاذ ولكن فيما
بعد سنقوم بملاحقه كل من نشر هذه الاكاذيب
والاخبار المزيفه على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او هنا وهناك الان
هناك الكثير من القاده الادولين الذين
اتصلوا وكانوا على التواصل مستمر معي من
اجل الحصول على المستجدات الاخيره بهذه
الكارثه وايضا لتقديم وعروضهم لتقديم
المساعدات في خصوص البحث والانقاذ
للعالقين تحت الانقاذ نحن نقيم كل هذه
المبادرات والاتصالات ونشكر كل من ساهم في
تقديم هذه المساعدات ونشكر الجميع الذين ي
كل ما بوسعهم من اجل
عمليات الانقاذ
والبحث طبعا هناك عدد كبير ايضا من رجال
الاعمال الذين
عليهم ان يتبرعوا
لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه والى
المنظمات الاخرى من اجل استخدامها في
المساعدات ومن اجل تقديمها للمواطنين
المتضررين من هذه ازلازل طبعا هناك تفاقم
في نسبه
الاضرار التي نراها في هذه المدن المدن
العشره التي تاثرت من الزلازل الان هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه كوارث هي مناطق منكوبه
وتم اعلانها كمناطق من كوبا سنستمر
بتسريع وتيره البحث والانقاذ وسنستخدم
الماده 119 للدستور ونعلن
حاله الطوارئ في هذه المناطق
بسبب هذا الزلزال وهذه الحاله حاله
الطوارئ ستستمر لمده ثلاثه اشهر
وسيتم اكمالها اكمال هذه الفتره واكمال
القرارات المتعلقه بذلك في المجلس في
البرلمان التركي
نحن نعيش احد اكبر الكوارث العالميه الان
ونسخر كل امكانياتنا وخطوطنا من اجل
عمليات البحث والانقاذ ونتحرك بشكل سريع
ونرى ان هناك
كارثه كبيره وهناك ظروف جويه سيئه جدا
هناك ظروف الطقس صعبه للغايه وبالتالي نحن
لم نتمكن من التسارع في وتيره المساعدات
هذا ونحن على ونحن على درايه في ذلك نحن
نحاول ان نصل الى كل نقطه في المناطق
المتضرره ونعمل على تسهيل كل الطرق قصار
جهودنا للوصول الى هذه المناطق لدينا
الصعوبات وهناك تحديات كبيره جدا وسنصل
الى كل نقطه متضرره في هذه المنطقه
وسنستمر في العمل في هذه العمليات عمليه
الانقاذ وعمليات انتشال كل من بقي عالقا
تحت هذه الان قالت باذنه تعالى سنتغلب على
هذه الصعوبات ايضا
وسنتخلص من هذا الدمائر الشامل الذي حصل
في هذه المناطق الاولويه الان لتسريع
وسيره عمليات جهود الانقاذ وايضا ايصال
المساعدات الى المتضررين بهذا الزلزال
وبعد ذلك سنقوم رفع الانقاض واعاده
الاعمار كخطوه اخيره
اخواني الاعزاء وفي هذه الاثناء
دوله قطر الان تستعد لارسال
عشر الاف حاويه الى تركيا وايضا هناك
مساعي وجهود لتقديم المساعدات الينا وعروض
لتقديم المساعدات الينا طبعا نحن الان
بحاجه الى كرفانات والى حاويات عدد كبير
منها يصل ولكن نحن بالمزيد بحاجه الى
المزيد من ذلك وسنقوم بتخصيصها الى
المواطنين المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
واشكركم شكرا جزيلا على حسن المتابعه